okay so this is about a statistical
disclosure limitation just to give you a
little background and I've been you know
involved in statistical agencies for a
long time I think I started back in 1981
at the statistical offices and where are
we going from here so just to brief and
just keep it really short overview of
what has been done traditionally in
terms of disclosure risks and disclosure
limitation methods risk utility analysis
which we saw a little bit from John and
then where are we going
why differential privacy and and it
turns out that in the last 5-10 years
we've been looking at sort of automating
our online flexible table builders that
we're really close to differential
privacy and how do we make that that
jump and that step to make our table
builders differentially private and
perhaps other future dissemination
strategies and discussions so this is
the traditional statistical outputs
again in the 90s 2000s traditionally
agencies statistical agencies released
survey microdata and they will put that
perhaps in in archives and and and allow
users to access survey data now it's
typically Social Survey data not
business data and there as I said if you
registered user to an archive you can
pretty easily get access to this data
and of course some agencies also release
lots of tabular data and these can be in
the form of frequency tables from whole
population counts from censuses are
registered weighted sample counts which
is not you know typically not thought of
as disclose of it at all so we're not
even touching on that and magnitude
tables the business statistics so the
types of disclosure risks that agencies
are worried about and of course are
grounded in our statistical legislation
our identity disclosure where
identification is typically referred to
in our
Mystikal legislation across europe and
in the united states and in our codes of
practice and of course we make
confidentiality pledges to the
individuals who are providing us with
their data that we won't reveal any
sensitive information about you etc so
this is really a fundamental risk of
disclosure that agencies are worried
about and then of course this leads into
attribute disclosure so if I do make a
real identification what can I learn
what sort of sensitive information can I
learn about that individual and then you
don't have to know exactly that about
that particular individual you might
learn a lot about a group of individuals
now this is typically not disclosure
risk per se and very hard to measure
quantitatively but group attribute
disclosure is a huge concern for
statistical agencies we don't want to
learn confidential information about a
group that may cause harm and you know
discredit the agency so group attribute
disclosure is also very important at
Statistical agencies in terms of Social
Survey data as I said identity
disclosure was the big issue in terms of
protecting the data confidential
confidentiality providing
confidentiality methods and one of the
big assumptions and statistical ages is
that they assume no reason no response
knowledge in other words with the fact
of you that you're selected into a
sample is not publicly known and
actually if you are in a sample don't
tell anybody because it's really easy to
reify people on a basis of three or four
variables and typically they would not
use perturbative methods so up to maybe
four or five years ago the agencies were
not thinking about perturbation and that
was in some places it was even illegal
to alter statistical data so there were
most of the protection provided was by
recoding grouping you might think of it
as a unanimity suppressing or variables
such as the high level geographies are
simply not released in the survey data
subsampling was a very typical way
especially because many countries will
provide sample Micro data from their
census like a 1% census microdata
attribute disclosure was of concern in
terms of once I make the identification
what can I learn about these individuals
so top coding was very common anybody
with an income above whatever $5,000 a
month would you know have their windsor
eyes have their values winterized
recoding and things but you really did
not see any perturbation going on in
these types of data sets frequency
tables whole population counts again the
identity disclosure the small self yes I
do well get to the census counts not in
social surveys we never accept I do know
in America they do swapping on surveys
that you would not see in across Europe
swapping in surveys so we'll get to that
and that so frequency tables now a lot
of time is spent at agencies about how
we design these tables how the tables
are defined what variables span the
tables how they're grouped in the
categories obviously you know we might
have 500 and I don't know how many you
said 520 ethnic groups but at the end of
the day when you see a census table
you'll probably only have a 15 or 16
groups and a lot of time is devoted on
designing senseless tables and again
traditionally they were hardcopy tables
right they would be on the web maybe you
could get some sophisticated web
crawlers or table crawlers to extract
parts of the table there but they were
hardcopy and they were looked at to make
sure that they were safe attribute
disclosure in tables is about the zeros
and we saw that a little bit with the
crap measure it's about what learning
about who is not so attribute is
disclosure and a table would be all a
table or wrote column a row of all zeros
except for one non populated cell and
that provides the attribute disclosure
based on less variables I can identify
an individual and then I learned
something new so traditionally methods
are pre tabular and as John said in the
census and the Office for National
Statistics they were doing swapping on
the census microdata prior to the
tabulations
and the idea of course in the tables of
many countries are just doing rounding
you know adding noise in that sense
rounding the the entries but the idea
was to introduce ambiguity into the
zeros so the problem in sense whole
population counts is not the ones in the
it's the zeros that are causing the
problems so and of course strict control
and what tables released so the nested
tables were avoided we didn't want to
have any disclosure by different scene
and I'm leading up to this because what
do we do now for a sort of an online
flexible table builder and you know
where are we going in the future
magnitude tables is very interesting
this is from business statistics and in
fact back in the 80s when disclosure
control just limitation whatever country
you're from started actually from the
business statistics and this was about
the the fact that the intruders the
adversaries are actually in the cells of
the table now we're getting a little bit
closer to the definition of differential
privacy back in with the business
statistics back in the 80s where the
adversary is in the cell it's a
competing business and they want to
learn about the other businesses in the
cell and there are certain you know
things that were known like the rankings
of the business who were the higher
higher earners and you know the lower
earners and the attribute disclosure
here wasn't called inferential
disclosure it's gonna be my next slide
was what kind of competitor learn with
sufficient precision so you are starting
to see you know probabilities here in
terms of how we protect magnitude tables
traditionally again as it was about
designing the tables minimum population
thresholds the same sort of thing in
frequency tables but here the protection
math that again the agencies weren't
doing perturbative methods that was all
about self suppression and of course
very advanced operational research in
mathematical programming you know cuz if
i suppress a primary you know cell how
do I protect that cell if I'm have a
table and and margins and stuff so it
was all about developing advanced
methods for cell suppression nowadays
well if we get into
setec data there is a bit of a move now
instead to do these sort of advanced
mathematical programming to determine
the best sell suppressions but instead
of leaving them blank to actually
provide the bounds the intervals or
actually imputed value so that's coming
as well so that's basically what it's
all been about in the 80s and the 90s
yeah you mentioned earlier on your
privacy concerns but I didn't see in the
methods that you were talking about
anything that was good
so yeah cuz I just wanted to keep every
punt so I'm glad you stopped me so as I
said after the disclosure in a frequency
table the whole population counts is
about the zeros so if I have a whole row
about zero zero zero and then one cell
that's so you know not zero that could
be group attribute disclosure I might
learn that all academics love Britney
Spears you know for example does that
cause harm or not you know yeah I don't
necessarily in the identifying
individual of course if there was a one
in that cell then I have individual
after you disclose it but I could have a
row or column of all zeros and then one
thousand in one particular cell so
basically I'm learning you know what is
not and that might cause harm especially
in his official statistics when you're
looking at I don't know if you know
ethnicity or sensitive questions or
income levels or who's collecting
benefits you know that sort of thing is
that there's one thing that's
challenging my intuition here so what
could cause harm is that why I'm
thinking of tables where you have
pockets yeah exactly are pockets of
ethnic groups and and believe me I think
I was mentioned that to Johnny after
9/11 they were sort of looking for these
pockets of ethnic groups individual
attributes closure
he's his best attribute disclosure
there's something different than a lot
of instances of individual attributes
disclosure or otherwise well yeah I
don't need to if I if I have a group
after school I don't need to identify
you first I just know that a certain
ethnic group is living in this area and
there's five you know whatever that
might you know mosques yeah because
nobody else in you know in the census
table I mean if it was whole population
counts it would be different it would be
survey data I'm talking about that
nobody that in the cell I'm learning who
does not like Britney Spears your
inability to give this a precise
definition as part of the problem
anyways I just wanted to give like a
really brief overview of where we're
going where we were so that I can talk
about where we're going yeah the idea
that I I know your ethnicity you know
that I can guess it with a 50 percent
probability is a very the exact models
on saying I know this neighborhood is 50
percent a particular group may have very
significant attacks
whereas saying you know I can guess your
ethnicity and have right half the time
may not pose the same kind of risk I
think that's the
so a lot of time of course a lot of
research back in the 90s 2000 was
dedicated to producing these types of
maps like I can't remember what they're
called in economics we called them the
risk utility maps this is Duncan at all
in 2001 and the idea was to the y-axis
to have a measure quantitative measure
of disclosure risk and on the x-axis a
quantitative measure of data utility and
we would sort of map our various we
would have different methods and
different parameters based on these
methods like adding noise and how much
noise and we could sort of plot our data
on these are you confidentiality maps
and the agency would set a threshold
I wrote the threshold as a horizontal
line but it could be very vertical it
was a very subjective process there'd be
a micro data review board and they would
say well you know it's just a little bit
extra risk we can get much higher
utility so generally those horizontal
lines have more of a slope to it and
basically you they would choose the the
release data which was below the
threshold and basically on the frontier
as we so for example so one example if
we are talking about surveying microdata
the disclosure risk is the probability
of reaiiy denta fication we would
typically use models to estimate or
perhaps record linkage or actually do a
probabilistic model to estimate the
chance that a survey an observed unique
person in my survey it's not a problem
if there are thousands like him in the
population they so it's so based on the
I have to sort of estimator infer from
my sample what the population counts are
so it's kind of like backwards sampling
that's one way of doing it
is unique in the population so it's so
in that case this would be a probability
space on my y-axis there are there ways
of course census data I don't have to
model anything it's quite you know whose
unique or not but typically because it
was all based on re identification spot
uniqueness turned in by respondent
represent a respondent yeah lots of
things going on another and talked
anyway but so I think for the y-axis
pretty clear you know how we estimate
probability free identification as I
said that would be the key problem to
avoid but the x-axis is very subjective
know we don't know what people are doing
with the data and usually we would use a
number of utility measures like how well
can I infer chi-square test or just
doing differences from margins or total
variation or things that we've heard
about previously so we might have a
number of these maps that we would use
so yeah that back when I did my PhD
which wasn't too long ago it was all
about how do we model the probability of
reaiiy denta fication and of course
Jerry Reiter was working on that a lot
too so so let's move forward now to
inferential disclosure so if you go to
the old literature's under statistical
disclosure control this is mentioned
inferential disclosure and it was all
about confidentiality confidential
information that can be revealed exactly
or to a close approximation so now we're
talking about probabilities here with
high confidence from statistical
properties of released and combined data
so there the notion of inferential
disclosure has been around for a long
time and the way the agencies dealt with
that was in their survey Micro data or
in their census tables was just to keep
very strict control as they said tables
were always vetted and they were hard
copy and they were put on the internet
and if you want an extract from the
table you might have a crawler but you
would you know you wouldn't be able to
design your own table
if you want survey microdata you go
register in a lab a Research Center RDC
and you would get the microdata so it
was all about keeping strict controls to
avoid this scenario of being able to you
know compose and combine sources so and
what's happening then in the last five
to news is that data is just being
locked away right and the government's
are in the legislation is like we want
open data and and put your data in ww
open data gov and so there's this
tension here between the traditional
ways of dealing with statistical data
and their confidentiality and sort of
this demand to provide more open and
accessible data from the statistical
agencies and of course you know things
are getting more worse because of the
amount of data that's out there in terms
of the data environment and what can be
used to attack the statistical data so
it's such a pension as we you know as
we're speaking now about how to assist
the disc allegiances open access to data
and so it was back and then I was
reminiscing with Cynthia I was back in
2005 when statisticians and for
statisticians computer scientists first
met and we had no common jargon at all
but you can see we've come a long way
for the young people who are now in the
audience so it was clear that the
agencies needed to think about more
rigorous data protection mechanisms with
stricter privacy guarantees and this led
to a number of collaborations and I
think this is our fourth formal
collaborations there was the first one
and then we had met in LA I think that's
2010 and then just in 2016 we had a big
program like this at the University of
Cambridge and and this one
so I so we have been looking at
differential privacy and I'm going to
show you some examples that I think that
you know that really fits in but one of
the key problems when we first started
talking to each other especially back in
Burton or when we're hearing about these
methods and they were basically folk you
basically focusing on interactive
mechanisms like how do you come queries
we're you know we collect the data we
want the data out there we're not going
to follow up on how many queries are
sent and how do you count them and so
this notion of this interactive
mechanism I think in the beginning was a
real barrier for statistical agencies
and statisticians to look at these types
of methods you know to use for our
statistical data but then you know
that's literature came out that we saw
these the non interactive mechanism and
this seemed a lot more you know
attractive and helpful for us because
now I could produce a safe object a
table builder order or you know a
private diplomat synthetic data and then
I don't have to worry about you know
what the users are going to do with this
data and I don't have to count queries
and spend privacy budgets so so I just
wanted to point out I think it's sort of
this mechanism on interactive mechanism
which has sort of I think made a focal
point for trying to introduce these
methods into our statistical systems did
you have a question hand up so the idea
is can we incorporate the differential
privacy into the SDL toolkit I think
there is a need to develop applications
which do take advantage of the non
interactive mechanisms and I'm going to
show you an example of what what is the
real possibility and I think we'll hear
tomorrow from the ABS actually so I'm
we're looking at these online flexible
table builders some countries have them
already and the ABS and we'll hear a lot
more maybe Australian Bureau of
Statistics will hear a lot more about
that tomorrow and the u.s. size of
fact-finder I'm not sure if that's
completely interactive or is that also
based on
happiness so EU has the table bill
didn't go on the internet and everybody
can use it and that's also pre tabular
so basically they mandated each member
state to produce a hundred and fifty
hypercubes
which is sort of the underlying input to
this table building but the idea in the
flexible table builder is it's a
web-based platform typically they'll be
drop-down lists in terms of the
variables and the categories of the
variables there might be some
restrictions on the number of dimensions
population thresholds so the the system
will if you produce a table and it's too
sparse so there's some sort of
underlying metrics therein within the
server if the table is too sparse so
you'll get a message back go away and
produce a new table but the idea is that
the SDL is on the fly and the idea is
you know it's done through the through
the server and it was clear that once
the agency start relinquishing some of
that tight control on what data is
released that we have to think about
perturbative methods so now we're
thinking about perturbative methods
which traditionally whelming for census
as i said they did rounding and things
so it wasn't too so much of a stretch
let's say so here as I said and we're
definitely focusing on inferential
disclosure is definitely relevant now to
look at differential privacy but just to
give you a little background I mean back
in the way that we do these perturbation
instead of just rounding we we knew we
needed to perturb with sort of longer
tails as opposed to random rounding and
and so basically look at a perturbation
mechanism P were the entries of them the
entries of the perturbation matrix is
our the conditional probabilities of
original cell value of I given its
original cell value of I what is the
probability to move to che and and I
think it was 2009
eight when we were in Istanbul and I was
showing these perturbation matrices and
when John said well that's actually the
difference in private mechanism so you
know things sort of came together but
this is how we've traditionally done it
you know we flip a coin and based on the
outcome of the random draw we would move
our categories around so this has been
around for a long time so you know again
we've sort of trying to bridge this gap
you know on some sort of dissemination
strategies that can really fit in nicely
with the computer science communities so
as I said the census counts are non
negative intervals integers now one of
the barriers to differential privacy is
that the agencies would not perturb the
zeros and of course that's not going to
be differentially private but it's
moving in that direction so property of
the table builder were that the zeros
weren't preserved there there were often
dimension restrictions so maybe only
three way tables or four way tables so
basically if I had like ten census
variables and I only allowed three way
tables it's a hundred and twenty
possible tables but the point is as I
said we can move to a non interactive
mechanism I know exactly what tables I'm
gonna allow and what cells I'm gonna
allow you know so this is this is why
it's a possible to think about
differential privacy in this framework
now what happened in 2006 in the ABS I'm
sure we'll hear about that tomorrow is
that they developed same participants
same perturbation strategies so
basically think of your census microdata
and each individual in the Micro data is
gonna get a little key a little random
uniform number and anytime I a grenade
that cell together
I will also aggregate the key and that's
my seed so they will always be perturbed
the same way so you can think as I said
you know we've got the perturbation
structure and I'll always if it's a ten
for this group of people they will
always be preserved to 13 you know so
it's fixed and so this again was a way
even though in theory the perturbation
happens at the time that the table is
called it's actually
set in advance so and then another
property is that the perturbations are
capped and I say I'm gonna have to move
along quicker margins were typically
perturbed separately which meant that
the tables traditionally were an
additive so they're usually with some
sort of iterator proportional fitting
going on and you know so lots of
different things that were because users
hate not added to the table actually I
think they're getting used to that now
another thing that we worked on is of
course in order to preserve the margins
at least an expectation and of course
you can also force these perturbations
to sum to zero is to put in this
property of invariance so that least the
margins the sufficient statistics were
exactly you know equal we would mess up
the inside of the table but they would
end up with the margin so we can put in
the property of invariance and we also
looked at various risk measures which
actually were measuring things like
activity disclosure all those zeros them
you know measures based on the entropy
which exactly identifies in a on-the-fly
setting which rows or which columns are
have degenerate distributions so I'm
just briefly touch on this paper this is
a collaboration that came out of
Cambridge last year and we published it
in statistical sciences and you'll see
Reno took the lead on this paper and
basically it was taking that model that
I just described the table builders and
how we might make this differentially
private and so again we're in the
discrete case we have a list of all
possible cells and remember I would know
all possible cells in advance it might
be Millions but I would know what they
are and we have a discrete mechanism in
this case where we're going to change
the set the list space from A to B we're
assuming that the structure of B is
similar to a and M is discrete and and
we started looking at the definition of
differential privacy in this setting now
we looked at the exponential mechanism
because we have count data and the
exponential mechanism is basically
discretized Laplace right so everything
stays integer
so we were motivated by two lost
functions the Laplace so we also for
comparison looked at the discretized
normal so I'll have comparisons than
that and then of course the utility is -
these lost functions and the sensitivity
in this case it was sensor data so we
looked at one was the sensitivity but
the issue here is that agency still are
going to cap you know they're not going
to allow a count of tend to go to 10,000
that will never happen and so this is
where the Delta comes in by introducing
this cap so for example if I I gave some
examples of epsilon 1 and 1/2 and what
happens is if I kappa dan7 you can see
that this now is my Delta so you get
this nice symmetric distributions and I
gave two examples of 1 and 1/2 and 0.5
so you can see exactly what the
perturbation vectors look like and you
can see that at 0 where I'm not touching
any I'm leaving the exact count it's in
for 1.5 is 63 and a half percent that
I'm actually going to leave that count
as it is so you know the levels of
perturbation or not that high once you
get into values of epsilon over 1/4 1/2
you can see 25% of the values are going
to stay the same and then of course the
tails spread out and but we're going to
cap them right so in this case I
arbitrarily said 7 - minus 7 and here is
an example on the top row you've got the
Laplace mechanism discretized Laplace
and you've got for an original values on
the x-axis here and on the columns you
have two sets of epsilon 1 and 1/2 and
then the right side the epsilon of 1/2
and you have the cap for the Laplace was
set at 7 and you can see that for
epsilon and 1 and 1/2 all my cells are
plus or minus 2 so we were you know so
we're not getting a lot of perturbation
here and in fact them one of my messages
is that it's actually traditional things
that we've been doing to preserve our
tables
probably less that differential prophecy
definitely wins because we're not it has
less bias and less perturbation in some
settings and of course if we go to a 0.5
then 96% of the cells will go to plus or
minus 4 now there is a caveat here
because we don't like negative values in
our table so we're pushing the negative
values to 0 so that's why the zeros look
a little off
now just comparing with the normal
distribution I want the same deltas to
make it comparable and of course the
tails are different and that means the
caps are different and so the Laplace M
is 7 in the normal M is 12 means the
exact same levels of epsilon Delta and
but you can see then the normal is not
performing as well as the discretized
surplus so that was clear winner so it
was no surprise that the computer
scientist just the Laplace distribution
so as I said the DP leads negative
values setting to 0 doesn't impact on
our DP a different differential privacy
but of course it does byes the
perturbations all non structural zeros
have to be perturbed indifference or
privacy and then of course it's the
margins what you show it here was just
the internal cells but what if I want to
have all three-way interactions all
two-way interactions on one all one way
and then the well the total would be
known so you have here different perhaps
different levels of sensitivity and in
fact the agencies can play with various
margins that they want these to be more
exact or less exact and you can sort of
play with the sensitivity in different
areas of the table now of course the
same cells same perturbation is
definitely not differentially private
because if I have a data base and I take
one away from the data base and produce
the same table they're all going to get
the same value except for one so there
are some adoptions here in privacy
budgets to spend if we need to consider
also the domain totals but just to show
you some applications now I generated
independent tables cuz that's hard right
it's hard to sort of reject the null
hypothesis of Independence and I
generated large tables and small tables
and applied these
know what those lines are and applied
these various utility assessments on the
left you've got first of all these are
big tables the average cell size is 100
and you've got the left hand side the
Laplace in the right hand side the
normal what you have on the top row is
the p-value for our chi-square test for
independence and of course these are
independent tables you've got the
Kramer's V which is the chi-square and
the loss function it is clear that the
Laplace is winning in a compared to the
normal perturbations and also that an
epsilon over 1 is providing us with
pretty good utility overall and of
course for the small table smaller
average cell size of 10 and lots of
negative values that were pushing to 0
this will buy us our results and again
the results would be more problematic
but just to say this is a real census
table there's lots of dependencies in a
real census table and so we really don't
see that an epsilon over 1 is going to
impact very much on our the results so
just to say that again this issue of
margins and composition theories but
just to say that the one big advantage
in statistical agencies to look at
differential privacy is that it's not
secret and we can compensate for the
error in our analysis so if we were
doing for example testing for
independence and we put this section in
the paper where we wanted to adjust to
likelihood ratio test we would simply
put in our distribution a noise
distribution into our likelihood and of
course you need a solver it's not
straightforward and we can compensate
for the error and carry out a proper
statistical test for independence
so just four examples here you've got
here on the upper level rose you've got
episode of 0.1 and then below that is
epsilon in point 5 and we generated
tables with independent and dependent
activity
so that the independent attributes for
the original you can see a 5% p-value is
fine and the for the power of the test
sets in seventy nine point three on the
original now what happens if I just
naively produce a chi-square test of
Independence you can see we go horribly
wrong with eighty six point seven
percent not our typical five percent for
rejecting the null hypotheses but if we
use it incorporates the distribution of
the noise into our likelihood ratio
tests you know we can get down to have a
carry out proper inference and I show
that for various levels of Epsilon's and
and caps so that's a really important
message that we should be accounting for
the error in the distributions into our
statistical modeling and in some cases
it's not so straightforward but there
are Bayesian methods which denoise the
data which can be used as well and then
hopefully that paper will come out in in
Journal of official statistics we did
some work with West out looking at table
builders for survey weighted data now
the issue of weights as we mentioned is
problematic because may be dependent on
the data but in theory you should think
of the sensitivity as the maximal weight
if we are thinking about differential
privacy and the weights don't vary that
much and we know that the sample size is
public and this population size is
public we can think of perturbing using
the average weight so it's a bit of a
stretch but that basically resolves to
the exponential mechanism as they just
mentioned but basically what that means
is that I perturbed the sample counts
and then I adjust my population counts
by using this average weight so if if I
had you know add two to the sample count
I would add two times the average weight
so and basically we looked at as I said
compare that with our methods that's
been used in Western and other methods
and the post randomization method that I
introduced earlier and we saw that
actually because those methods are all
biased with zeros and if the cells
aren't too
small that the differential privacy
outperforms those methods at the same
levels of perturbation so synthetic data
is a big area of research that
statistical agencies are undertaking now
how do we make that differential private
and you mentioned on the map and of
course we heard about the challenge
differential privacy synthetic data or
we heard from York and John about
producing noisy counts and then
reconstructing the microdata to me it's
my intuition here is to carry out these
sort of sequential regression modeling
and tweaking the estimating equations
that's what I would do and we heard
yesterday or two days ago with the
predictions and adding noise to the
predictions I would probably tweak the
estimating equations and get safe
parameters and then just have your set
of predictions from those parameters
remote analysis servers I think might be
a way to go that everything I said about
online flexible tape ability we can
think of having a system as well which
will provide safe regression results or
logistic regression results so that's
another way to go to provide
differential private analysis so is
differential privacy useful in the SDL
toolkit well it allows statistical
agencies to consider new and open ways
there's a seven-day is disseminating
data so that's you know really
attractive and people are asking you
know well should we should we replace
our traditional ways of protecting the
data the sort of notion of five safes
that maybe we'll hear in from Australia
course anine suppressing subsampling and
this to me i don't think we should stop
any of these practices but these these
will feed into the privacy budget and I
was happy to hear from John that there
was a way to think about a privacy
budget if you have aa priori sampling
going on because you know it's not the
same as having whole population counts
so we need to think about that and as I
said I I think that adding
perturbative noise with DP is probably
if you have large enough counts can
actually provides more utility than some
of our current STL methods so that was
rather enlightening and I think well if
you've got this problem of invariance
and that's being discussed so I won't go
there but it does provide a formal
privacy guarantee for inferential
disclosure because this is now you know
the real problem that agencies are
facing when they need to sort of open
and have more accessible data so
challenges I think the focus has to be
in developing the non interactive
mechanisms because agencies aren't going
to don't want to start tracking you know
what people are doing with their data
how to set these privacy budgets in
light of our other sort of standard SDL
techniques looking at synthetic data or
remote analysis servers how do we extend
this further to other types of
statistical data beyond the counts and
then as a academic how do we train our
in future social researchers and social
scientists to analyze messy data and as
I said in my comment the fact that these
distributions are known it's so you know
it should be so clear that we should be
accounting for for these for the noise
and and of course this is not a standard
course that you have in your master's
programs how do we how to analyze messy
or data with measurement errors so it's
something we need to think about in the
future when we're training our students
[Applause]
five saves so if I prove to you that
suppression and of course I necessarily
feel differential privacy why should I
hold on so we still are mandated by this
issue of re identification and of course
I why should you hold on to them because
in some settings maybe we need less
perturbation if you have the non
perturbative methods or more or more
with the privacy you know you can put in
more traditional SDL practices are
inconsistent with formal privacy and the
inferential disclosure guarantee is
stronger than the reai efficacious but
if I did subsampling which is a non
perturbative method and not
differentially private and then I need
to and then I do some noise addition
musing do you pee would you agree that I
would have less bounds on this epsilon
could I be more lenient on my epsilon if
I combine it with other methods what you
do that you can't use most traditional
STL notes I know I'm not saying on their
own I know that they have to be combined
with the DP methods but I'm just saying
that we would be we could relax a little
bit some of the level of perturbation if
we had these opera a non you know non
probabilistic methods every step has to
respect the rules so
what does it mean simply is right so to
a first approximation multiply the same
thing great times but you have to find
that epsilon it seems to me they
especially those of us who are in
statistical agencies can make a lot of
progress if we go all the way down to
the bottom and say this is stronger in
principle just close your protection is
stronger than inference
maybe I just yeah yeah I do agree but
maybe I'm just being conservative
because you know insiders say whereas
otherwise in thickness good I shouldn't
make things worse no imputation whatever
it may actually work against you or you
might do it in a way that actually
breaks your privacy lost budget which is
a real risk
so you emphasize a lot of the importance
of non-interactive mechanism I see why
that's so important for statistical
agencies but is there still a role for
from the perspective of agencies for
interactive mechanisms for subsequent
analysis reserving some privacy budget
for analyses that like we've heard we
can't expect the synthetic data to you
know support all possible analyses
Ashwin talked about you know I think for
verification
you know maybe in the in the context of
RT C's or something any thoughts along
those lines I I can only refer to John
because I don't have the experiences
that John is actually having trying to
deal with this in real in real practice
so
what's going on for me the synthetic
data I've never thought of since I never
thought that anybody would use you don't
see any publications based on synthetic
data to me synthetic data is to allow
users to pass data on the Internet to
develop their models but eventually a
researcher is going to get access to an
RDC somehow then you have another set of
problems yeah now you have a set of
problems in the RDC but you know see
you're not in the near term single role
for differential privacy and at the RDC
step or argue yes I say that but no I
don't the 2020 census is going to be
subject to a privacy laws budget that
also applies to any uses after the
original release including those in the
RDC and that's a scary thing when I say
it out that's very scary I don't think
any other agency would say that doesn't
make any sense to say you did this
pristine well executed differentially
probably the public use data and then
you let anybody go do it are you seeing
do anything they want we never did that
we always very techie oh yeah and I'm
not saying that it's very difficult to
check the outputs they have to sign
their life away be you know so so we
have to check from their father didn't
let you try
so that could be in the Census Bureau
but that would not hold in any other RDC
in Europe yes if I can okay the heart
problem
I believe with selling perturbative
methods in the past has been keeping
secret that perturbations yes which
meant that you could not mathematically
verify whether the hypothesis you were
trying to analyze what's spanned by the
space of models that were used to
produce the confidentially you can now
so the space of models used to produce
the cup of the privatized version any
census has a proper mathematical form
once you represent the census as a
histogram so you can confirm whether
your hypothesis as long as it's from the
set of allowable ones was spanned by
what we did it's something you can
compute in row the proper standard error
and that's the discussion if it's not
then you need to make a case for why the
difference between what was spanned by
what we did and what you want to do is
important if you have to queue up for
privacy lost budget and then when we do
the new of the new queries the new week
reissue the confident eyes data updating
to reflect those queries that is in the
conceptual design for the 2006 but not
oh that's all paper we're right that's
five nice sentences but you can't do it
because we don't have the software to do
it we are all bowing to you and
following you
and of course we're at a good plug for
the panel discussion about where we're
going with statistical agencies and john
kindly and volunteered to be on that
panel as well because i know you worked
hard on the tuesday panel i really think
that we do a disservice to our subject
matter expert colleagues why not
continuing to point out that the defects
of the traditional ways of doing this
have to be addressed it's not they can't
be papered over but I still think
there's a need to do you know the
probabilistic modeling for the risk of
reaiiy denta fication is measuring
something else but you know the micro
data review boards are looking at those
types of measures because that's what's
grounded in the legislation how many
view a survey what is the chance you
know that that person can be very
identifiable
[Applause]